le prix louis delluc décerné aujourd'hui
au film le roi et l'oiseau un dessin
animé de paul grimault qui n'a pas
encore été projeté dans les salles de
foot de distributeurs c'est le plus
grand réalisateur de dessins animés
français que viennent de couronner les
jurés du prix delluc
c'est la bergère et le ramoneur son
premier long métrage animé qui le rendit
célèbre 1952 voici maintenant un extrait
du dessin animé récompensé aujourd'hui
le roi et l'oiseau halo halo et il est
exactement six heures 25 minutes 30
secondes une mère viennent d'entrer dans
la ville basse hubert thiel
entrée on a vu une basse
alors alors
n'est ce pas surprenant henry chapier
que le prix louis delluc soit remis
ainsi un dessin animé sa première fois
ça arrive je crois oui il y a tout lieu
de s'en réjouir et paul grimault
méritait une récompense parce que c'est
le plus grand cinéaste dessin animé mais
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de vous dire
tout de même que c'est un peu tard parce
que ce monsieur a été célèbre déjà en 47
avec le petit soldat qui était à
chef-d'oeuvre il est un peu tard de
penser que paul grimault mérite
l'académie et les plus grands prix il
est temps peut-être de pensée qui n'a
jamais eu l'argent pour continuer de
faire des films qui ont enchanté le
public
je crois qu'il est peut-être temps de ne
pas toujours accordé un prix lorsqu'on
n'a pas résolu un problème autrement dit
le prix delluc est plus que méritée mais
il faut s'occuper d'urgence du dessin
animé en france et de paul grimault qui
est encore extrêmement jeune malgré cela
je mur et qu'ils peuvent faire des longs
métrages quand on voit la région